[Music]
spencer din woody working against
avery bradley knight feed inside
rejection by anthony davis
you played great defense the jazz has
struggled and there's a six point ball
game
in their possession so bare and that's
going to be a jump
multiple effort stop the ball get back
into the pitcher
block the dunk layup attempt trying to
force things stu
and that falls into the hands it's
another transition opportunity
blocked by a.d as he gets back in
transition
lebron 1-2 defense that play that a.d
made prime example go up get contact
with the ball without getting too much
contact
with the offensive player
[Applause]
can have a couple of subs in a moment
for the lakers and
loses it again ahead of the pack is
avery bradley
first pass isn't open you want to make
them make an extra
there's that big point guard you're
talking about anthony davis the steal
he's going all the way drive kick cook
yes sir team again matching it as
anthony davis picks off an
easy interception there and then takes
it down and gets the assist
to quinn cook a.d eight points three
assists three rebounds
so kyle lowry no rondo again tonight for
the lakers we thought we might see him
he went five on five blocked by a.d and
again he hurt his shoulder
ricky rubio was the mvp of the fibo
world cup over the summer
a.d the leader in the nba in swats
and he's hurting at the other end here
comes lebron spin and score
607 to play lakers are up
by a point
bogdanovic will take it out doesn't mean
he's not going to get it back
he's getting it back well no barnes
going to the basket
dropped by davis lakers win it on the
block by a.d
wow he's back to the basket and a
dribble alive
but they did and boy he got tripped up
and then ran right into
the wall anthony shot blocking leader
davis
number one in the nba the verticality of
david
stumbling barnes boy he just suffocated
him
yeah he just really look how he just
he disappears in here against all of the
length
of anthony davis and the lakers they're
the ones that escape with a win
and he gets it taken away hawks on the
attack trey
davis from behind oh he is a great
offensive player but
he is showing all kind of different
skills though on the defensive end to
their eighth straight win
in their 15th of the season
anthony davis gets his second block the
other end
first says i got an easy win
not with anthony davis on the floor
nothing easy in the paint
and uh offensively
truly great i'm not sure it might even
motivate them a little bit more like
this one
lebron james up high it doesn't matter
a.d throws it down then gets it back and
scores
how about that quick good play by caruso
to tap the inbounds pass
158 in a game this year
and lost by a point back on october 30.
what by davis again a.d
protecting the paint behind the back to
danny green from lebron
got it mavericks off to their best start
since 2010 11 their championship year
dodges
rejected by a.d and it's kept in play
good creativity by caruso
davis so turnover lakers have it quinn
cook
he's going to go all the way laying up
and in
last few games where his defense has
really been on point
and he's not afraid to miss a couple of
shots you know an ultimate slow start to
the year for him
as it's blocked by a.d help out
they rebound and when especially when
they run the floor good block by anthony
davis
and then running the floor throughout
the course of his career
and the fact again he's playing through
injury i mean there was talk that hey
he's gonna miss some time
after the injury on christmas day no he
plays a back to back here's davis again
they cannot keep him away from the rim
really getting after them in the first
quarter defensively
at the other end they do it again
anthony davis yet another rejection for
the lakers
i just like the way they play team ball
in that scenario
eight blocks and david just took it then
next trip down anthony from the blind
side
yet another block so baker's making them
pay using the fundamentals and all the
equipment
derrick rose trying to wander in and
take it away by a.d
here he goes anthony davis all the way
a.d all good pass the trailer is called
a look at anthony davis stealing it away
from
derrick rose and then getting the assist
to kcp who
just barely have excrucia he played well
both sides of the ball and played some
significant fourth quarter minutes too
for the laker team nilokina that's
swatted right back
by anthony davis here comes rondo that
was the pass yes it was
fly by caldwell paul falwell pope
after the deflection by anthony davis
deflected and picked up by lillard
stolen by davis
into james hottest player in the nba as
ariza drives inside
right there mcgee and davis and another
slam dunk
as the laker defense leading to offense
[Applause]
lakers already with six assists on uh
nine field goals made so they're sharing
the ball
there's some bars get it out of here in
this contest
as harrison barnes shows him the ball
way too soon a week that has been
[Applause]
so he's got a double double as they
turned over look darren fox and
i'll tell you what what a pass what a
opportunity pass yes a lot of misses
derozan intercepted by davis
putting up big numbers blocking shots
and steals mckee
big finish i'll switch off lebron's on
him now
they'll double they'll triple underneath
anthony davis forget about it
but then the grizzlies get it right back
and again deny
but a foul cleanly but
as they tried to recover it they take it
away and
here comes the second attempt and
there's the foul
[Applause]
ball to get the friendly hop off the rim
grizzlies at it again all going right
past kcp
davis who chased back up for kcp all the
way
throw it down but then the play by a.d
i mean what a play because milton just
knew i've got an uncontested layup
and then all of a sudden somebody jumps
out of strew holiday lonzo ball in the
backcourt ball run the point and then
it's
d.i brandon ingram with fabers and zion
williamson
holiday block by davis that's his second
here's lebron james
kicks it daddy green
has been able to do especially the
position that he has placed his team in
in the eighth spot in the western
conference and vying for a playoff spot
so of course he's going to be mentioned
for oh goodness who says i can return to
favor he was at 18 the other night the
most that he's had since
the first week in february oh blocked by
davis is john morant
right to the rim davis because moran had
got on that trampoline
he was ready to throw it down but didn't
anticipate
from behind anthony davis
fighting to keep the possession alive
and a turnover davis
all over the sixers defensively kuzma on
the drive left hand
finish the lakers are doing just that
adam and the crew standing by american
express halftime report
another steal this is davis davis going
all the way
on a two-handed jam no one's going to
confuse with the
defensive minded bad boy pistons
let's do it the easy way i should have
known right there
yeah when he slowed down that he was
going to do
last season 29 percent from downtown off
the steal
his heart chased by brook lopez and
rejected by giannis
to be reminded of his athletic ability
there you go way to get back he doesn't
give up on the play
good job with lopez and tyler hero and
kick his nun
and you got to take advantage of him
nice job that's that's the play that was
hurt the bucks in the first half
miami without a couple of veterans
janice takes
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
magruder out to heartless barclays on
the drive
he went to the rim with bad intentions
the buck's down 19 donovan mitchell spin
cycle giannis was there
ah and royce o'neil able to pick it off
at midcourt pay that off at the other
end here's
donovan mitchell he's cocking it back
trying to throw it down giannis right
there to thwart that
russell down to the ground off the ball
on the weak side chris paul involved in
that chris paul
yas takes it away ahead for hill back
for giannis what a pass
out of the kumbho and george hill
beautiful
basketball first a great defensive play
give me that cp3
get it early get it back watch that
bounce pass no look number
from george hill and then get out the
way in backboard
swaying monster jam mean mug
another takeaway levine ahead for laurie
[Applause]
janice got the rebound here's aaron
and yes
this elevates on him don't lose but but
looking at us get back in the place
sprints back he just had a huge dunk
he could have laid back it's fine i'm
the all-star
let that just let it go replace takes
the pass away from marketing
like you said defensive reaction doesn't
think
for even a second oliver goes about six
eight or listed
uh at six eight here's the steal
bledsoe on the drive goes right at
mccollum
and scores middle seconds first half
there is anthony got the step goes all
the way shot
kobe bryant comes to mind lebron james
comes to mind where they start
to try to work the referees a little bit
more slow coaches
turnover percentage always one of the
best in the league ranked one or two the
past four or five years this year
he's down on the bottom right believe it
saves it for giannis he pushes zeller
out of the way
before practice started to try and get
me some free equipment
and all these guys were working up a
lather just a tremendous sweat
optional shooter rounds on the road and
guess how many guys show up
i'd say the majority get outside your
shoulders like that they'll call that
but
he ended up paying the price on that one
jordan drives a dump down pass picked
off by giannis giannis
goes to the left hand drives kicks it
back open shooter
brook lopez the miss 14 seconds on the
reset yes
picks off the pass middleton
janitz
[Applause]
but i don't like to see him go short on
free throws short on three pointers
like this though he short hands the
steal
and long rhymes the dumb
see you later you get that deep ball
away
edmond sumner to rebound goes in on dean
kenzo see you later
catch him in transition like this great
job by yana she's chasing him down he's
passing the league at it
right over sabonis this has it doesn't
tj warren inside blocked by
anas
[Music]
[Applause]
let that thing go here let it fly
there's a little psychology there too
just
let it go well he let that go
106 to 100 they arrived in milwaukee and
got to bed
after 5 a.m today up back to back
for the nuggets teams have no sympathy
on the bus now
wilkins loses the basketball the nasa's
sprints right down in the center of the
floor
[Applause]
[Music]
but here's will barton off the cut they
do a lot of this kind of cut off a
jokage hits him on the back cut giannis
great job
the buck's lead by 14 giannis has 25.
giannis
blocks deandre ayton five on the shot
clock
you may get a foul call on giannis away
while we're talking about giannis wesley
matthews just hit his 4-3 he's four for
five
he came ready today yes there it is as
we often say
[Music]
lebron trying to spin oh
hard 300 thousands on the line here
grant
right here good effort davis the steal
ahead
oh rejected audena cumpo
just gummed hollis jefferson
boucher is putting his mark on this game